[Music]
you're looking at the White House we're
minutes ago the Trump administration
announced it will be setting a national
standard for fuel economy in cars and
trucks now this move targets California
and will essentially revoke the state's
ability to set its own fuel standards
even before the announcement was
announced the idea was fiercely attacked
by California's governor an
environmentalist in our eye on Earth
series CBS this morning a showcasing
original reporting focusing on the
health of our planet Greenland's melting
ice sheet is contributing to a rise in
sea levels that could threaten millions
in low-lying areas the situation became
more urgent this summer when 11 billion
tons of surface ice melted in just one
day Seth Doane visited Greenland's
glaciers to meet some of the scientists
on the front lines of climate change
icebergs broken off glaciers fill fjords
ice melting here in Greenland is
affecting sea levels around the world in
fact with all of Greenland's ice sheet
melted sea levels could rise by 23 feet
worldwide
we choppered out to Helheim glacier
which holds enough frozen water to fill
the entire state of Pennsylvania a foot
deep you can see the cam now scientists
are perched at the glaciers edge NYU's
David Holland and his wife Denise who
manages logistics people say follow the
money well this is a story really about
follow the warm water water melts ice
quicker than air and so the ocean can
melt this ice sheet much faster than the
air Denis Holland took this video
showing a giant piece of Helheim glacier
breaking off or calving last summer the
ice chunk was so big it could stretch
from lower Manhattan to midtown in New
York City
it was huge chunks small chunks
everything just just broke apart and
it's one big jumble of ice this is a
radar detector Collin Raye NYU team set
up radar equipment that peers into the
glacier to measure its movement and
thickness the icy surface is deceiving
one comes up here doesn't see a problem
right and so the potential problem is
when we put our probes down in this
floor down to the bottom and we detect
large volumes of very warm salty water
because you know that could melt the ice
back and that's not sustainable
Greenland's ice sheet shed around 11
billion tons of surface ice in just one
day in August that's enough to fill
around 4.4 million Olympic sized
swimming pools Loretta
Samaras Coastal kulusuk Greenland says
they're feeling climate change with more
ferocious storms so how is just noise
because of this extreme weather because
of the wind because uh strong rain and
nearby in the picturesque port town of
tassel at this is all Inuit culture this
is all Rasmus Paulson took freelance
work at this Museum of Inuit culture his
winter sport adventure business had a
shorter season last year was extremely
good we had a lot of snow a lot of eyes
we were able to do dog sledding all the
way into the first week of June this
year I had to close down my business for
wind activities in the middle of April
summer came sooner someone came very
very much sooner coming off the ice
sheet in winter this glacier David
Holland and his team have been surprised
to learn just how finicky the atmosphere
is people say climate will change by a
degree or something in the tropics I
don't think that matters but when you're
at the freezing point - a half degree
below is freezing plus half a degree
above is melting one degree is
everything
they're collecting data to understand
what is happening so scientists can then
tackle the question why for CBS this
morning Seth Doane Helheim glacier
Greenland good work out there on today's
CBS this morning podcast Seth and his
producer share details of their
reporting from Greenland including what
locals say about the effects of climate
change and to learn more about what you
can do to help the environment and
everybody can do something we invite you
to go to our CBS this morning Instagram
page for advice from teen climate
activists Greta toon Berg and others
Greta you know was here at the table the
other day she's like Congress Phoebe the
cost of emergency room visits